well it's that time again it is one
o'clock in the post-meridian eastern
time it's market takes i'm dion robolin
uh walking you through all things this
week the biggest economic reports the
things that are gonna matter to the
market the economy and to everyone out
there who is is watching these and i
think we're at a very precarious time
right now uh with what's going on in the
economy and with the markets and so you
know i know you could have been anywhere
in the world and you're here with me i
appreciate that
let's get into it look today on market
takes this is our live stream for the
wall street journal i'm going to be
walking you through
this week's big housing reports and
we've got a bunch of data coming out in
the housing market uh some of it
forward-looking that i think is some of
the most interesting and important we
are going to dive into that we are also
going to take a look back and kind of
examine where we are how we got there
and the current state of the housing
market because things have changed quite
a bit from where we were just a month or
two ago so
look let's let's dive right in we're
going to dig into all that um and i want
to talk through you talk to you about
first this pending home sales report
that we got this morning we've got the
fhfa federal housing finance agency and
the case-shiller home price index coming
out this week we've also got
construction spending and reports on a
number of other things also our sneaky
economic report of the week i'm going to
talk to you about why that is and why it
matters so look first let's talk about
this pending home sales report that we
got today
i think that one was big and it's going
to tell us a lot about the economy and
you know generally speaking what we can
expect to see moving forward in the
market um
but before i dive all the way into that
let's hit reverse let's hit rewind a
little bit and talk about the signs that
we're seeing of this cooling housing
market so i talked a little bit about
this uh in my last report that i did um
earlier this month about why the housing
market is actually starting to cool down
if you guys remember i did a report or i
did a video in february saying that oh
you know economists are saying the
housing market's finally going to cool
down that could be a nice sign for those
of you buyers who are looking to finally
you know buy a property
you know purchase your first home the
market's supposed to cool down only
supposed to rise three to five percent
this year well to start the year that
didn't happen i talked about some of the
reasons why that hasn't happened uh as
well as some of the signs we're seeing
that it now is starting to flow into the
economy so i want to talk through a
little bit of that right now just those
signs that we are seeing and and how
they've led into the reports that we got
today
first of all sales of existing homes
fell in may to the lowest since july
2020 and they've been lower year over
year every month since august 2021. so
we've seen this number decline
consistently uh over the last six months
and we've seen it decline year over year
from that 2021 pace which was just crazy
uh every month since august of 2021. so
i talked to the national association of
realtors last week to kind of say like
okay what's what's really going on and
the numbers are actually worse than i
had kind of anticipated we're seeing
year-over-year sales down 8.6 in may
that was the largest decrease since june
2020. now if you just stop right there
for a quick moment remember june 2020 we
were still in the pandemic you still
really couldn't go tour houses you you
couldn't it was really hard to get a
house and a contract we were also still
kind of dealing with the throws of the
recession the sort of the shortest
recession on record
so june 2020
is a particularly interesting analog
when we're comparing you know anything
to that because that's a very special
month after that month housing sales
really started to pick up and take back
off but that was the month where you
really couldn't compare it to anything
may and june of 2020 were just
incredibly low because that was part of
the government shutdowns going to see a
house you really couldn't do that
because of the covet 19 restrictions
so again we're at the lowest since then
um
also
you had the year-over-year sales down
8.6
uh that was largest like i said since
june which was down 10.2 percent prior
to the start of the pandemic in 2020
this is the lowest since we've seen
since december 2018 right
year over year sales of homes under 500
000
are down 12 and a half percent uh
according to national association of
realtors so overall sales are declining
but you're still seeing a broad pickup
in terms of the sales price of very
expensive homes those homes are still
selling homes 500 000 plus are still
selling and they're still increasing the
price homes under 500 000 the bottoms
had the bottom has really fallen out and
the lower price the home actually the
less the sales are and that's largely
because these interest rates are just
completely pricing people on the lower
end of the home buying spectrum out of
the market
uh coming into this month pending home
sales which is the report that we got
this morning had declined for six
consecutive months and we're at the
slowest pace in nearly a decade so we're
going to talk more about that in just a
minute but remember pending home sales
were on a real decline existing home
sales on a significant decline and we
had a report from redfin that showed us
that almost one in five home sellers had
lowered their asking price in may that
was the largest or the highest numbers
since october 2019. so you've got these
consistency themes
going on especially in the lower price
portion of the housing market homes
under half a million dollars where peop
they're not selling home sellers are
cutting their prices homes are staying
on the market longer and we're seeing
that redfin
has been doing a really great job of
putting out new reports tracking the
kind of turnaround that we're seeing in
the housing market and we've seen
another report on from redfin showing
that more than 40 percent 40 percent
that's two and five home buyers or home
sellers excuse me in hot markets like uh
salt lake city boise sacramento uh more
than forty percent of those people were
reducing the price that they had listed
their homes at so cutting the prices
redfin also found that home buying
demand had fallen to its lowest in more
than two years so that means home tours
offers on homes and people reaching out
to get the help of real estate agents to
buy a home had dropped to it had seen
its largest annual decrease since 2020.
uh this again goes back to redfin is
tracking these things in june and in
kind of real time and for the weekending
june 23rd that was last week on thursday
uh sales had decreased at this rapid
rate in large part because mortgage
rates had risen to 5.81 percent we're
almost hitting six percent mortgage
rates that's an important number i want
to get into that a little bit later but
the mortgage payment on the median
asking price home in the us increased to
2 500
from 1700
a year ago and in fact just at the
beginning of the year
since the beginning of the year the
national association of realtors expects
that or projects that home price the
average price that you're paying for a
median priced home has risen by 800
that's significant again if you were
able to afford to pay two thousand
dollars a month nineteen hundred
eighteen hundred dollars a month you
were comfortably above that median
before now you're well below it and so
we're pricing millions of people out of
the market
as these rates go higher so
that i think takes me into
the pending home sales report that we
got this morning that was a huge big
massive surprise really caught a lot of
people off guard myself included
pending home sales ended that six month
decline
actually rose not by a lot but
economists were expecting a pretty big
drop of 2.5 percent according to factset
and we saw an increase on pending home
sales of 0.7
here's why that's important pending home
sales is a forward-looking indicator it
means you know it's more it's of the the
housing market day that we have it's the
most forward-looking because it looks at
homes that haven't finished selling as
in a lot of folks agree that they're
going to buy a house the seller agrees
to sell it then you get under contract
you go through your inspection you've
got all that that goes on for a month or
two depending on where you are in the
country and then the home actually gets
sold so this is an accounting for all
those homes that just you know were
under contract i've agreed to sell it as
the seller you've agreed to buy it as
the buyer but we've still got some
negotiating to do we've still got some
inspections to get through
like i said economists had predicted a
decline of two point five percent uh
after a four percent decline in april uh
and we saw actually an increase of 0.7
some economists were predicting a
decline of as much as four percent of
those pending home sales so this beat
was a real shocker and suggests that
maybe the housing market isn't rolling
over maybe we're not turning from that
seller's market to that buyer's market
because you saw that change happen and
just as quickly as it happened it
snapped back because those big
corporations blackstone blackrock kkr
carlyle group
they're out here buying homes but also
you've got people that just you know
individual investors that have a lot of
money available and they see that the
home rates uh the home selling market is
is turning and now they've got the
opportunity to go out and buy some
things that maybe they wouldn't have had
before now that homes are staying on the
market a little longer they can make a
deal they can offer a kind of below
asking price offer and that home seller
is going to consider it where they
wouldn't have three or four months ago
so that's big and something to watch
we still are though moving lower on
these numbers pending home sales was
down 13.6 year over year so still we are
declining pretty significantly from that
pace that we were at in 2021 uh lawrence
jun he is the chief economist for the
national association of realtors uh he
said in the report this morning despite
the small gain in pending home sales
from the prior month the housing market
is clearly undergoing a transition
that transition very clearly happening
um like i said according to lawrence
calculations 800 increase since the
start of the year in the uh median
single family in the median single
family home
right here in the u.s
this is again i think it's worth
watching for a number of reasons but we
are also going to get into some more
data that we've got coming out this week
but look out for next month's existing
home sales i think that's going to be
big
where is the housing market going and
this is important not just if you're a
home buyer or home seller but for the
overall pace of the economy home sales
and home prices make up a big piece of
that cpi basket the federal reserve
watches or that pce basket that the
federal reserve watches
if they continue to sky higher that puts
more pressure on the federal reserve to
do more the more they do the more they
slow the economy the more the economy
slows the more likely we are to head
into a recession so
this is worth watching even if you're
not thinking about buying a home look
the bottom line is don't sleep this
pending home sales report
tells us
something's changing things are changing
in the market rates did come down a
little bit in may as you know more
investors moved into that treasury
market we saw yields on the 10-year
benchmark treasury note fall down back
below that 3 level which is a very
important level ever since then in early
mid may they've really spiked up and and
come back higher uh right now today i
think we're sitting about 3.18
on the 10-year so that again means
mortgage rates dipped a little bit but
then they went right back up and now we
are approaching six percent so looking
forward we've got the fhfa federal
housing finance agency mortgage or
housing market index and the
case-shiller 20 city home price index
for april those are coming out on
tuesday
those are important because look we get
a deep dive into what happened in april
the case-shiller report does a deep dive
into 20 different cities 20 different
major metropolitan areas that are
driving the overall housing market and
it breaks out what's going on in each
one of those if you dig into that report
if you've got the time it's really
helpful in terms of just breaking out
what trends are happening what's going
up what's going down and what's
consistently moving in a certain
direction the fhfa report is the
nation's only public freely available
house price index measures changes in
single-family homes from all 50 states
and over 400 american cities so if
you're looking for a
deep dive on everything happening
throughout the country you want that
fhfa report if you're looking for 20
major metropolitan areas that are really
driving the market right now you want
that case-shiller report and both of
those are coming out tuesday
9 a.m they're going to tell us what
happened in april april was the first
month where mortgage rates really
started getting up past that four
percent to four and a half percent
approaching that five percent and now as
we approach six percent here in june
april was when that change in the
housing market started to happen from
historically low still low interest
rates to now getting back to that median
even high level that we see
we also get construction spending for
may that's on friday that's coming out
at 10 a.m
that's generally held up overall
construction spending has held up pretty
well but it is clearly slowing down when
you look at a chart that construction
spending number year over year and month
over month you see it just starting to
tick down still positive overall um
hasn't turned over like we've seen
existing home sales new home sales
pending home sales in the real estate
market so will be important to watch
that construction spending report that
we get from may friday at 10 a.m
that could also be a potential recession
indicator we know that when construction
spending or when the economy hits a snag
construction spending really slows down
significantly and considerably so watch
out for that the residential
construction sector up 1.3 in april does
that continue and do we get another uh
solid strong report
my sneaky but not so sneaky report for
you to watch this week uh pce personal
consumption expenditures it is the fed's
favorite report on inflation normally
you know we've done an entire uh live
stream market take special on pce uh we
didn't do that this weekend i thought it
was a less important report because the
fed already said when that cpi report
came out earlier this month that that
changed their thinking they raised rates
by 75 basis points that's three times
the rate they normally raised by uh the
fed already said hey look we're watching
cpi that report moved us and caused us
to change our our direction of thinking
well they can't now when pc comes out
say oh well now pce is different that
that changes our thinking entirely still
important because pce and cpi are
calculated differently pce
is when it looks at inflation it looks
at substitutions as in if you were
buying steak now you're buying hamburger
cpi just says okay you're buying beef
pce says oh well you went from steak to
hamburger that's an interesting change
you made you probably did that because
the price of steak is rising so much and
you're making changes also a number of
different indicators in there and the
core rate on pc has declined pretty
significantly so the fed could see
themselves in a better position if that
report continues to show its cooling
down which cpi did not show that's going
to give them a little bit of comfort so
certainly watch that but the fed already
said the cpi report that came out
earlier this month changed our thinking
and we're going with that so
not as big a deal as it normally would
be so listen that is gonna about do it
for us here on market takes thank you
again for joining me dion rabone
reporter for the wall street journal
look our takeaways for what we're out to
look for this week uh housing is clearly
in a tough spot but that pending home
sales report that we got this morning at
10 a.m showed us that maybe the market
is starting to turn maybe investors
maybe home buyers a little glimmer of
optimism are starting to rethink the
market or were at least in may and
they're back in but we'll need to see
more reports on those data the existing
home sales report for may was bad what's
it going to look like for june going
forward
and is the market really turning over or
are these enterprising and auspicious
investors saying hey you know what this
is a buying opportunity let me get back
in there
this week's housing data is going to
tell us some things about where we've
come and where we are as well so be sure
and look out for all those construction
spending
case shiller and the fhfa report on
tuesday construction spending on friday
and of course the not so sneaky sneaky
important report the personal
consumption expenditures report that's
coming out earlier later this week check
that check that out as well thank you
for joining me here on market takes i've
been dionne robon for the wall street
journal i hope to see you back here
we'll be doing at the same bat time same
bat channel we're off for the fourth of
july next week but stick with us we're
going to keep going with market takes i
appreciate you guys tuning in and we'll
see you next time